Film Courage: Do you have any suggestions
to help writers brainstorm?
Scott Myers, DePaul University Professor/Screenwriter/Creator
Gointothestory.blcklst(dot)com: Yes, well
first of all let's imagine that we've got
10 tracks in our brain (that our brain can
do 10 things at one time).
One of those tracks if you're a writer should
be always sensitive to and aware of is ideas
that are out there all over the place.
They are in newspaper articles, they are in
conversations you hear with people at a coffee
shop, they are on the radio, they are on the
click, click, click thing.
I know (for example) David Rabinowitz and
Charlie Wachtel who wrote BlacKkKlansman I
interviewed them and said well how did you
guys come up with it and I think David said
Well I was trying to avoid writing so I was
doing the click, click, click thing and I
stumbled on this Facebook article about this
guy Ron Stallworth, the first black police
officer in Colorado Springs, so when they
did this thing with the Ku Klux Clan so that’s
how they discovered it.
One thing is just be conscious of it.
The other thing is be intentional.
Like everyday you should be thinking about
story ideas.
Now people are not going to necessarily, it’s
going to vary from person-to-person but there
have been times in my life where I’ve literally
said I’m going to come up with an idea a
day (every day) I’m going to come up with
something.
And a third point to that related is this
Dr. Linus Pauling who was the only person
to win two Nobel prizes and he has that saying
“The best way to come up with a good idea
is to come up with a lot of ideas.”
So that’s a third point that you can do
is generate a lot of ideas, keep a file like
I’ve got a Word file stretching back to
20 some odd years ago with literally hundreds
and hundreds ideas (most of them awful).
But you keep working that muscle and then
eventually I think chances are that you are
going to surface something.
Now then you have to assess the ideas and
so there are certain questions you have to
ask like “Well is this big enough to be
a movie?
Who is the audience for this?
What is the hook?
That central conceit.”
When I sold K-9 I remember going into an executives
office and they said “What you guys did
was so brilliant.
You took the buddy action comedy formula (the
police cop) and you put in a Rin Tin Tin.”
Who was like the biggest star in Hollywood
from back in the late 1920’s and 1930’s.
I learned a very valuable lesson there which
is you always when somebody gives you a compliment
even if you didn’t mean it you go “Yes,
that’s exactly what I was thinking!”
And it wasn’t that at all but that idea
I could walk in at any point in time in 1987,
I could walk into any producer’s office
or any bar where people are hanging out and
“What are you working on?”
“Yes, I’ve got this idea for K-9.”
Loner cop, new partner and a police dog.
They would see that.
So the hook there is the police dog.
Nobody had done that you know.
So you look for like INCEPTION, the idea to
be able to go inside someone’s mind.
GROUNDHOG DAY, we are living that same thing.
What is that thing that is going to set it
off from something else.
Those are some keys.
You have one part of your brain going be intentional
about it, be generating a lot of ideas and
hoping that you will come up with some really
good ones, some strong ones off of that and
then assess them to make sure that you feel
like it’s big enough to be a movie.